[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
patrick mahomes was in interviews
yesterday and we were waiting for him
comes out of i should say he was in
meetings and uh comes out
and he sits down and he has no idea
about the scottie miller news and that's
where i start the interview where i
asked patrick mahomes
did you hear the big news i did not
what's the big news it's all over the
facility i'm guessing
what scotty miller the bucks wide
receiver had to say
no i did not hear it he said that he is
the fastest player
in the nfl and he says he's faster than
the cheetah tyree kill
oh man that's a interesting take man you
gotta have confidence in yourself though
i'll give them that
okay but uh tyrique is already commented
by the way
he said good for him but uh do you guys
have a bulletin board
and if you do do you have any material
on that bullet like how motivating
is this for you patrick and the chiefs
yeah i mean i think you're more
motivating
uh on yourself and being in the super
bowl if you're not ready to play for the
super bowl i don't think you uh
you're gonna get ready so uh uh he is a
fast dude he's a great
great receiver um but uh i like him i
like my guy
all right verse anybody if i had you
raise
tyrique okay so if he ran backwards
could he run 100 yards faster than you
if he went backwards and you went
forward
man i feel like i feel like i can get
him in 100 running backwards i don't
know if the start i feel like at the
start he'd still be pretty quick
we all we always talk about it i i
always say if he was just if we just ran
a straight hundred i think i needed at
least
30 yards
[Laughter]
but i mean we could test it well you
would probably have to give brady 30
if you ran 100 yards with him do you
think
i mean if me and brady both ran 100
yards i feel like both of us
need to be on the auction i don't think
we're going to plan on doing that
anytime soon
uh have you hung out with brady off you
know other than uh
playing a football game i have not
actually uh
just having crossed paths in that way
i've heard a lot of great things about
him
he's a great guy to hang out with but
have not
gotten that opportunity i could see you
playing golf i think you guys would
probably do okay yeah i'm sure we'll
have a lot of fun i'm not sure
how the scores would look but i'm sure
we'd have a lot of fun out there on the
course
do you know when will you know your
first play in super bowl 55
i probably won't know only coach reed
really comes out with the full first 15s
and all that different type of stuff
until
that friday before the game he kind of
gives me a little sneak peek before
everybody else to make sure we're good
to go
um but uh you'll have a good idea of
what he's thinking uh
kind of during the week how much input
do you have in that
i have a good amount i mean he uh him
coach the enemy
um and uh coach kafka both come to me on
pretty much every single play right
after we run it or throughout the day
throughout practice and they ask me
uh what i'm what i'm liking what i'm
feeling how i feel this can attack
certain places uh
our defenses um and it gave me a good
idea and that i
actually it's kind of a funny story
whenever uh last game of the season when
uh
chad henny uh got the start i made my
own
first 15. how close i can get to code
the coaches and
i was actually pretty close i have a
good feel for what coach reed's thinking
if i would have told you back in college
one day you're gonna go toe-to-toe with
brady in the super bowl what would you
have said at that point
yeah i mean i i thought it would uh i
didn't know he would be on the 10th day
[ __ ] years i'll tell you that
i thought it was going to be yeah i'd
have been on the nfc somewhere but uh
i mean uh it's it's it's special i mean
i've had a great start to the career but
it's because i'm in a great organization
with a lot of great people around me and
i just try to
take advantage of the all the
opportunities that i've been given
and not don't let them take them for
granted and i understand that it's been
a blessed situation and i'm gonna try to
do whatever i can to get another super
bowl ring
but when did you know you could play at
this level or
on the level with the great quarterbacks
in the game
i didn't know i could play and be in
super bowls like this
until i was in the nfl and i made my
first super bowl i don't think uh
you feel you know that you have a great
team around you and you know that you're
doing everything the right way but until
you get to that game
um to this game you don't understand
exactly what it takes and so uh
i think going into this this season i
had a lot more confidence in myself and
my teammates because i knew what it took
to get to the super bowl
what did you take away from the loss
against the patriots in the afc title
game a couple of years ago a lot
a lot of times you know the the bulls
couldn't get by the pistons the pistons
couldn't get by larry bird in the
celtics like there's certain teams like
you have to get by them and once you get
by them
then you never look back and i don't
know if you learned anything
uh after you lost that game i think
the biggest thing that we've learned uh
since that game is how to deal with
adversity and i know it's kind of cliche
and people
people talk about it but whenever you
lose a game like that and you realize
that it's over there's nothing else
like you you have to watch the super
bowl on tv just like everybody else
you learn that you have to find ways to
battle throughout a game and
if you look at that game we didn't start
the way we wanted to in that afc
championship game
and then we couldn't figure out ways to
get ourselves going until it was too
late and uh
i think we've learned that now that when
we've gotten these deficits now we
understand that we have to attack and
get get back in the game because if you
don't you'll run out of time
i was also wondering when i watch you
play you know you got great footwork and
obviously arm strength but i didn't know
if you played other sports i know you
played baseball but
were you a basketball player i was a big
basketball player i thought i was going
to be a basketball player growing up i
was kind of still i was taller kid
i played point guard and all that
different type of stuff and then i got
to my freshman year of high school when
i was
like six two six three whatever i am
right now and i never grew again
and i figured uh how i played it wasn't
going to make it in the nba who did you
want to be
oh when i was when i was younger i mean
i i mean obviously you watched you
watched
when i was really young i watched
michael jordan and stuff like that but
then it was alan iverson man dude
watching the ai
uh and all that crossing over it i
didn't have the quickness but i felt
like i could still make some moves
out there did you ever meet him i i
haven't
got to meet him yet i mean uh a
tremendous player and i
hopefully one day i'll get to meet him
he's patrick mahomes he's uh joining us
uh on behalf of well you want to make
sure you get to the big game on behalf
of airshare the safe and simple way to
fly private i'm assuming mom
and dad are flying the airshare they are
and uh we have a great partnership they
actually fly my parents and my family
out to every single home game
um and so they're able to be there for
every single home game that we have
at arrowhead which is awesome makes it a
lot easier for me and then in the off
season i get a few flights here and
there as well which uh which helps out a
lot
as far as me trying to make some golf
trips and some business trips and stuff
like that
that's nice that's nice you know being
this entrepreneur
what's the best thing you bought since
you signed your contract what would
surprise us
whether it's big or low or small
the best thing that i bought um i mean i
bought a car but i mean that's super
simple i feel like everybody buys a car
i actually bought a i bought a
plot of land that i'm going to build a
house in kansas city i figured
my contract has a couple years on there
so i'll be here for a little bit so
i got a plot of land and i'm gonna build
a house out here would you have a like a
mini
football field a basketball court like
you're going to have the full i know
you're having a daughter so
you know you're going to oh yeah oh no
we're uh we i do have like
a half a football field so i can get
some work in with some guys out there
i have a basketball court but don't tell
brett beach all right
that's not for me that's for that's
really cool of course it is
but uh and you'll have you'll have a
little golf stuff out there as well
uh we had aaron rodgers on a couple of
weeks ago and i said look i
i'm watching jake from state farm the
arms are getting a little too big i
i'd like to test jake from state farm
patrick i i think he might have some
illegal substances in there
dude all of a sudden man i mean the year
before like he came out
was kind of a fit dude and then all of a
sudden the next year i'm like man dude
you're making me look small over here in
these commercials dude you got to
please calm it down a little bit i think
it should be in your contract he has to
wear long sleeve shirts
he's at least got to wear a little bit
looser that when we're
well rogers went short sleeve and i the
the next commercial i don't know if
aaron was doing a party pump but
like i wouldn't mess with jake i i
really wouldn't yeah i'm about to get
him out here uh you know maybe
run uh play a little bit of full bag
tight end for us you know
you might have had to make some plays
you're good with kelsey
uh bruce aryan said that the buccaneers
have a big advantage by playing
at home and i you've already played
there this year
and there's no fans or at least you
don't have the true home field event
is it a big advantage for them to be
playing at home
uh i mean i will see i guess i mean i i
feel like we've we
we've had the lucky enough to go there
and find a way to win a game
um they have a really good football team
that's playing better football even
when we played them last time um but at
the same time
i mean it's a super bowl i mean you're
going to be on a big stage no matter
what
um but uh as far as an advantage i mean
we will see because it's the first time
it's ever been done
how many times you go to the line of
scrimmage and you go this is going to be
a touchdown
uh there's certain looks it's not as
much as you think um
the the crazy part is have time like oh
this will be a nice completion i'll
throw it to these guys and they somehow
score touchdowns and so i'm just like
running behind them and i'm just kind of
like oh my gosh these dudes are still
going
you get a lot of good looks and you
understand why coach reed calls plays
and
and coach b enemy and they they'll call
a play and when they call and
get that perfect look you know there's a
good chance that you're going to have a
chance at a touchdown
i i don't understand what's going on
with eric the enemy here patrick
i i i don't think he's gonna get a job i
i don't understand
what am i missing here i mean i i know
you know selfishly you get to keep him
but
i mean he's older than mike tomlin and
he hasn't had a head coaching job here
patrick
yeah it's it amazes me honestly i mean
the first year you kind of were like all
right this is his first cycle through
and then
last year uh the interviews and you're
like for sure he's doing the job and
then this year i mean
i mean if you look at his track record
then the way he's able to coach us
uh the way he's able to lead men and
which is uh people
say that but to be able to lead a locker
room of people from every different
background and every
different race and everything like that
and be able to be the leader
of the locker room is a special talent
it's a talent and he's able to do that
and in the way he's able to i mean go
about calling plays throughout the game
and
i understand that we we have coach reed
and coach recalls plays
uh but there's there's a ton of input on
coach the enemy and he calls a ton of
plays in our game plan and
it just gets overlooked and i mean who
knows what it is but it's
it's a lot it's a loss for everybody and
else in the nfl and a game for us and uh
hopefully he gets his chance because
he'll he'll succeed with that wherever
he is but uh
um if he doesn't we're glad enough to
have him back again
we've come a long way since you dented
my uh my face in the man cave in new
york where you threw
the football that was before the draft
where you put it i think
right on my nose with that uh that large
float that i had
you know what chief should have known
right then they had their guy
yeah no for sure that that definitely i
think rose
for that throw uh how's mom by the way i
was worried about her when you got hurt
and can you make it
can you can you tell me did you have a
concussion or you just said the
concussion protocol
i was in the protocol okay uh i don't
know if it was necessarily actually a
concussion but i mean you never know but
they never know
exactly with those injuries but i know
i've had no
symptoms no lingering effects since and
so i feel completely normal
uh i feel like i played completely
normal this last weekend yeah mom was
upset did you uh did you find out what
she was tweeting during the game when
you got tackled
yeah man it's hard to i try to try to
keep my family on twitter as much as
possible
it's hard to tell your mom what to do i
better let her go
just being a mama yeah you can't scold
her you know it's normally the other way
around but you can't go mom you can't be
sticking up for me like you know you're
getting in a fight out on the playground
no exactly but uh you know she just
she's it's all out of love but uh at the
same time you just
gotta kind of kind of calm down it's a
game of action and
you go out there and you fly around and
people get hurt here and there
uh give another plug for airshare before
we say goodbye
yeah i mean it's a great company i mean
kansas city based
uh but have really spread throughout the
whole entire uh
whole entire country and uh been a great
partner for me from day one
uh great people and i look forward to
continuing our partnership
for the long run well good luck great to
talk to you again have fun in
tampa thanks for joining us as always
yeah thank you appreciate you
that's patrick mahomes that was
yesterday we taped that after the show